- Ça va bien.
- Cette ergothérapeute a pour
mission d'aider Rachelle
Lassonde à redevenir autonome.
- Bravo!
- Là. je retourne.
- Réapprendre même les plus
petits gestes.
- Ça fait que je m'assois.
(rires)
- Rachel Lassonde lutte pour
retrouver la mobilité perdue
après une opération au cerveau.
- Attention à vos doigts.
- Oui!
- Trois professionnels se
déplacent ici à tour de rôle.
Au total, une trentaine d'heures
de service chaque semaine.
SHABNAM TAHERIAN, ergothérapeute
- En ergo, moi, je peux aller de
quatre à cinq fois dans une
semaine. Je les vois pour
45 minutes. En physio,
c'est la même chose aussi.
- Avant la pandémie, cette
réhabilitation aurait eu lieu à
l'hôpital.
GUY BIBEAU, directeur, programme
Déficience intellectuelle et
physique, CISSS de Laval
- En fait, dans le contexte
de la pandémie, on a dû faire
de la place à l'hôpital pour
accueillir des usagers qui ont
la COVID, ce qu'on a appelé
la zone rouge.
- Mais depuis janvier,
faute de lits à l'Hôpital
de réadaptation, on a déplacé
la réhabilitation d'environ
80 patients lavallois à leur
domicile. Une transformation
forcée, mais qui semble
efficace, surtout parce que
la réhabilitation se fait
en fonction du domicile.
- Leur cuisine, leur salle de
bains, leur chambre à coucher
aussi. Donc pour le client,
c'est plus réaliste. Il voit un
peu pourquoi on fait certaines
interventions.
- Québec veut généraliser
cette approche, baptisée
Congé précoce assisté.
LIONEL CARMANT, ministre délégué
Santé et Services sociaux, Qc
- Ça permet à l'individu de
faire sa réadaptation dans
son milieu de vie et en plus,
ça a un gros impact sur notre
réseau de la santé, puisque ça
décharge les lits, ça décharge
les infirmières.
- Ah, elle veut y aller.
Ah bien, câline!
Viens, mon bébé.
- Rachel Lassonde pense que
la présence des siens
a contribué à ses progrès.
- Ma main, elle bougeait plus.
Il bougeait pas, ce bras-là.
- Et elle souhaite que ces soins
à domicile lui permettront
bientôt d'en sortir.
- C'est marcher, marcher un
jour, revenir comme j'étais.
Ici David Gentile,
Radio-Canada, L